con dolor por la tragedia y más de una
lágrima en chiapas los familiares de las
víctimas del accidente de camión en el
sur del estado mexicano despidieron a
sus seres queridos que estaban en
tránsito hacia eeuu
lastimosamente ya que está el cuerpo
ya ya pues por lo menos tranquilos en el
sentido de que si lo encontramos ahí sí
que usted sabe que esos sueños
americanos que que van por por comprar
nuevos o darles un mejor futuro a los
hijos a la familia
tenemos también desde guatemala de donde
procedían la mayoría de los migrantes
dieron un último adiós a las víctimas
con oraciones muchos rindieron homenaje
a la memoria de los afectados y pidieron
por la seguridad de los sobrevivientes
sus sueños era cruzar y llegar en los
eeuu la necesidad que teníamos tengo dos
hijas una de 11 años y una de 2 años él
vio la necesidad que teníamos cada año
miles de inmigrantes emprenden esta
travesía ya sea a pie o en medios de
transporte como camiones un flujo que ha
ido al alza durante el último año tras
los hechos la última caravana señala al
gobierno mexicano inmerso en un
operativo para frenar la llegada de
inmigrantes al país
estamos caminando y seguimos siendo
agredidos no importa si agarramos carro
un importe se agarra mostrarles su
distinción es completamente desmantelar
esta caravana destruirla golpear y sin
ninguna respeto por toda la familia
ahora los sobrevivientes del accidente
se enfrentan a una disyuntiva continuar
su camino rumbo al norte o volver a casa